bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
cette nouvelle édition de rentes hebdo
et dans cette émission grands reportages
en roumanie où entre un million et demi
et deux millions de roms vivent dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
certains d'entre eux voudraient aller
dans l'ouest de l'europe
et puis l'actualité c'est un programme
phare de l'union européenne erasmus est
il menacé de disparition faute d'argent
c'est la question de la semaine par
l'espagnol xavier français de 25 ans
part à barcelone pour terminer ses
études en économie
l'aventuré race muscles commencent
popularisé par le film de cédric
klapisch
ça c'était le bon vieux temps car
l'auberge espagnole pourrait bientôt
devenir un film d'époque très populaire
en europe le programme d'échangé
universitaire créée en 1987 et est
menacé de disparition l'année même de
son anniversaire il n'y aurait plus
assez d'argent pour continuer à financer
les études sans frontières des jeunes
citoyens européens
la crise a conduit certains états
membres à réduire leurs contributions au
budget de l'union européenne et à
limiter certaines dépenses
erasmus en fait les frais chaque année
grâce à une bourse moyenne de 366 euros
quelques 230 mille étudiants font
plusieurs mois d'études ou de stages
dans un autre pays
une occasion d'apprendre la culture et
la langue des voisins en france le
premier ministre souhaite que le
programme erasmus monte en puissance
pour qu'il bénéficie à plus d'étudiants
issus de familles modestes
pourtant au parlement européen le
président de la commission des budgets
alain lamassoure tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
faute de moyens le programme sera
bientôt en cessation de paiement alors
erasmus est il déjà mort
retour à bruxelles nous sommes avec
sylvie guillaume bonjour je députée
européenne membre du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors erasmus c'est sans doute l'un des
programmes les plus symboliques les plus
populaires en europe
alain lamassoure votre collègue du
groupe ppe affirme que ce programme est
menacé d'extinction
est-ce que erasmus va mourir j'ai fait
le pari que non et je pense que nous
serons nombreux à faire ce pari là mais
monsieur lamassoure a fait un coup de
génie
il a fait un buzz absolument parfait
justement prenant appui sur le fait que
erasmus est non seulement un programme
qui fonctionne mais un programme qui a
été repérée qui est très visible et qui
parle à beaucoup d'européens
moi je ne pense pas que le programme
erasmus soit menacée il ya un problème
de liquidités de trésorerie positif et
le bain c'est lorsqu'il dit n'était pas
tout à fait exact j'ai même en situation
je pense qu'il utilise parfaitement bien
une technique de communication qui va
permettre de rebondir sur d'autres
sujets ce qui me semble que monsieur
lamassoure voulais dire c'est qu'il ya à
une vraie problématique sur les fonds
sociaux et qu'il ya une vraie
problématique également plus générale
sur le budget et en prenant ce sujet
tout à fait emblématique de la jeunesse
de l'accès à d'autres cultures de la
libre circulation du de la confrontation
des langues et des études
bref houcine un moyen de répondre à la
crise aussi il a pris un sujet
parfaitement symbolique pour je crois
stigmatisé le fait que certains états
membres sont très réticents à apporter
le budget européen sont très réticents à
aller vers des budgets qui sont
j'ai de lutte contre la crise et pour la
croissance et donc je crois qu'il
voulait stigmatiser sein sur l'avenir en
fait c'est un appel lancé aux états
membres pour qu'ils l'aident plus
d'argent dans le budget communautaire
qui est réduit par rapport à aux autres
années c'est un peu un budget de crise
c'est ça nous il ya ça je crois je crois
qu'il ya ça généralement sur le budget
c'est à dire comment on se donne les
moyens de sortir de la crise d'aller
vers des politiques de relance et c'est
vrai que le vin budget européen fort
bien bâti qui agit en ce sens est un
moyen de surmonter un certain nombre de
difficultés que rencontrent les états
membres dans leur territoire
donc il y a je crois ça il y aussi je
pense aussi mais vous la tireuse
répétaient ils à la répartition entre
les différents fonds les fonds de
cohésion les fonds de la pac
moi je pensais avec mon groupe aussi que
les fonds de cohésion sont fondamentaux
justement pour aider les états membres à
sortir de la crise donc je crois que il
y avait aussi ça qui est en ligne de
compte
comment on contribue comment on renforce
ses fonds sociaux européens agissent
souvent c'est la grande question en
temps de crise et les états manquent
d'argent il n'y a pas beaucoup d'argent
dans les caisses
d'où peut venir l'argent et surtout
quels arbitrages doit-on faire parce que
on peut maintenir décidé de maintenir le
fonds social européen erasmus mais
est-ce que ça n'implique pas que
d'autres programmes doivent être
sacrifiés sacrifier n'est pas le bon
terme à mon avis je pense qu'il ya
manifestement à travailler faire sur la
consommation des fonds ce travail de
fond il doit être fait sur un sms par
exemple on a modifié le programme sera
modifié pour être élargi à plus de
public puisqu'on avait constaté
effectivement que il y avait certaines
bourses qui n'était pas consommer c'est
le cas en france
peut-être que là aussi parce que la
crise aidant les gens bougent moins les
jeunes un peu envie peut-être de rester
sur des formations courtes en prenant
moins de risques pour essayer d'assurer
leur avenir dans un contexte qui est
assez délicat est resté difficile donc
il y avait manifestement à travailler
sur l'adéquation de ses fonds avec les
besoins et la consommation qui en était
fait d'aucun travail de fourmi sur
comment ces fonds sont bien utilisés
mais plus globalement dans un contexte
de crise où chaque pays pris isolément
ne pourra pas s'en sortir seuls s'ils
continuent d'agir dans un contexte très
très restreint de ses frontières
il faut qu'ils aient une impulsion il
faut manifestement que l'europe agisse à
son bon niveau et son bon niveau c'est
la solidarité s'est passé
le financer cela c'est l'objet de la
discussion budgétaire qui en cours
actuellement entre le parlement et le
conseil
est-ce qu'ils sont un peu tendus et
millet ctive mans
vous dites il faut qu'il y ait un
sursaut vdu peut-il venir on dit quand
même la même chose depuis depuis des
années qu'ils qu'il faut que ça change
mais on a l'impression que ce que la
crise est toujours là et que les choses
n'avancent pas d'où peut venir ce
sursaut lutter contre la crise apprend
le diverses formules et divers biens et
la fois le traité et puis les
discussions que nous avons depuis
plusieurs années au plan européen je
crois que commence à marquer les fring
c'est le cas par exemple avec la taxe
sur les transactions financières on voit
qu'on avance sur un certain le sujet
mais c'est très lent c'est trop long et
on s'est toujours plaint effectivement
en tout cas dans mon groupe de la
petitesse l'étroitesse des réactions et
surtout du délai de ce type de réaction
moi je crois que deux années durant
le parlement a été très ferme dans ses
convictions mais a lâché face aux
conseils et face à l'augmentation
nécessaire et du budget en tout cas une
stabilisation sur réellement les moyens
de répondre aux besoins des citoyens
on a lâché deux fois peut-être que la
troisième fois ce sera une autre une
autre affaire une autre façon de voir
les choses et que le parlement sera
beaucoup plus ferme sur les prix est ce
que vous pensez qu'il va naître sur ce
programme erasmus qui continue à
intéresser beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes
en europe ce qui a quand même plus de
trente deux cent trente mille étudiants
qui bénéficient de ces bosses
est-ce que sur erasmus il y aura quelque
chose et ce qu'est ce que ça va être ce
qui va être sauvegardés je pense que le
programme erasmus comme on le disait au
démarrage à un problème de liquidités de
trésorerie qui sera surmontée parce que
dans le même temps les états présentent
les factures donc à un moment donné ce
qu'elles disent que les états consomme
pour leurs citoyens
présentant la facture les commissions
aux impros bien qui est que cela est
nécessaire
donc je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
soucis sur erasme et ce en quoi cette
année évidemment et que la discussion
budgétaire sur l'année prochaine sera
manifestement très rude et très axé sur
la sauvegarde et des programmes sociaux
et des programmes en direction de la
jeunesse
ça se sait vraiment à paris que nous
devons faire collectivement merci sylvie
guillaume on a bien compris votre
message alors cette semaine on a parlé
d'un pays en crise l'espagne un catalan
défi madrid
artur mas c'est son nom le gouverneur de
la région appelle à des élections
anticipées et veut faire sécession
regardez ce zapping des télévisions
européennes des élections régionales
anticipées seront organisées le 25
novembre en catalogne le parti d'artur
mas le président de la communauté
autonome pourrait obtenir la majorité
absolue
de quoi renforcer les velléités
d'indépendance de la région le président
de catalogne n'a fait qu'une seule chose
signer le décret de convocation des
élections anticipées
il appelle sa région à s'émanciper de la
peur et des menaces
il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir peur puisque
aujourd'hui personne ne peut utiliser
des armes unilatéralement contre son
peuple
personne ne peut utiliser les armes
contre un peuple qui s'exprime
démocratiquement pacifiquement et à la
majorité
en signant le décret artur mas a assuré
que le mouvement d'émancipation de la
catalogne serait pacifique et que
personne ne devrait menacer ce mouvement
ils veulent que la catalogne devienne un
pays et non plus une région l'espagne
le nationalisme catalan est déjà
important mais il est exacerbé par la
crise économique
prix explosent en catalogne une région
qui est au bord de la faillite voilà
alors nous avons été rejoints par
griselda pastor bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes correspondante ici à
bruxelles de la radio espagnole cadena
ser alors l'espagne est déjà aux prises
avec une crise économique importante
on voit qu'il ya là une sombre tempête
constitutionnel en tout cas vu de france
est-ce que kiki et 7 artur mas est ce
qu'il y a vraiment une menace
aujourd'hui de sécession delà de la
catalogne ou alors est ce que c'est de
la provocation
c'est difficile à dire comment ça va
finir bon alors on masse le président du
gouvernement catalan il a été élu après
un gouvernement de gauche socialiste
gauche ni gauche indépendantiste il est
un bel héritage dans l'eau très
charismatique qui s'appelle sur le
joueur qui a été le président de la
catalogne pendant toute la transition et
et jusqu'à l'arrivée de ce nouveau
gouvernement de gauche ce qui est
nouveau c'est que ces partis
nationalistes n'a jamais été en parti
indépendantiste
c'est parti nationaliste a fait la
transition espagnole en expliquant aux
catalans que l'indépendance n'avait plus
de sens dans un espace démocratique mais
que les cats a été une nation mais dont
la vocation n'était pas d'être
indépendantiste
qu'est ce qui a changé maintenant bon la
crise certainement c'est un élément très
important mais il faut voir aussi en p
tous les problèmes dans lesquels l'état
espagnol et schumi alors justement que
demandent précisément les catalans et
plus particulièrement
artur mas il reproche de trop donné
d'argent à madrid y un problème fiscal
oui il ya un problème il ya un problème
fiscal qui est historique donc la droite
catalane qui était droite il faut je
vois la place et il faut la placer cette
droite qui est intégrée par une
coalition
donc le parti démocrate chrétien et
fondateur de la démocratie chrétienne
européenne donc membre de la démocratie
et l international en tout petit parti
démocratique va être le mien et après
vous savez c'est parti combien de
démocrates qui est en partie du parti
libéral européen ils sont dans les
groupes libéraux donc depuis toute son
histoire politique
il considère qu'il ya un problème
d'argent entre la catalogne et l'espagne
c'est ce souci permanent d'entraidé
campagne électorale il ya un problème il
ya un problème aggravé
parce que le pays basque et n'avait
autant concert économique
pour bien comprendre ça veut dire qu'il
ya des régions dans l'espagne qui
ramassent des impôts qui les utilisent
et qui rend à l'état c'est dont ils ont
pu les joindre
il ya des régions qui reçoit dans le
teint c'est que l'état leur donne c'est
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent aujourd'hui des
catalans en fait est ce qu'on reproche à
madrid
faux ça c'est très difficile à dire
deux temps mais voyons laisse manière
fine transition héliades guerre civile
gagné par franco quarante années de
dictature donc d'espagne bien commencé
une transition dans laquelle tout le
monde doit céder en paix mais donc il
faut effacer certains fantômes du passé
donc la catalogne fait la transition en
parlant d' indépendance et liberté et
arrive à la transition un devoir et
constituer ses discours pour dire ça n'a
plus de sens dans un état démocratique
il ya une constitution qui essayent de
réfléter la pluralité de l'état le
problème c'est que dans ces moments
présents
l'idée de cette constitution a touché
son toit est acquise et surtout en
catalogne
mais colette un espagnol ne veut pas ou
ne peut pas la changer parce que les
gens le parti qui a la majorité absolue
et en espagne avait pas se permettre ça
et est ce que vous pensez que ce type de
mouvement peut être dangereux pour
l'espagne et plus généralement pour
l'europe est là toujours d'énormes
dangers quand il ouvre quand tu ouvres
quelque chose qui implique des
changements terrible que tu sais pas où
ils vont mais quelles sont les
nouveautés dont il ya un parti
nationaliste qui n'a jamais été
indépendantiste qui tout d'un coup se
dit poussé par le citoyen et qui n'a
d'autre choix que de demander
l'indépendance qui a un parti
majoritaire en espagne qui est en partie
unita liste absolue qui est confronté à
une dégradation de l'état avec une
monarchie qui s'effondre qui étaient les
symboles de l'état pendant des années et
une crise terrible comment ça va finir
on n'en a aucune idée
eh bien merci beaucoup ri zelda pastor
de nous avoir exposé ses quelques
éléments d'éclairage en cycle de temps
alors je propose de partir maintenant en
roumanie nous sommes allés près de
bucarest à la rencontre de la communauté
rom objet de vives polémiques en france
nous avons voulu comprendre quel était
leur situation leur sort le sort de ces
citoyens roumains dans leur propre pays
c'est un reportage signé ahmed tazir
avec georges et à beaucourt
il est midi passé leur premier repas de
la journée des pommes de terre et des
champignons
les enfants sont impatients de manger ou
cuisine à l'extérieur une famille rom
comme il en existe beaucoup en roumanie
11 enfants et petits enfants à nourrir
et galina dimitriou ne perçoit que
l'équivalent de 20 euros par mois
dette sociale
moi je suis dans la galère pas
d'électricité depuis 25 ans pado
on est livrés à nous mêmes nous sommes
affronte chagny une vingtaine de
kilomètres de bucarest un village comme
beaucoup d'autres ouvrent hommes et
roumains ne se croise pas des roumains
plutôt à l'aise des roms dans le
dénuement des conditions de vie
difficiles pour le gard guina d'autant
plus que son mari ne peux pas l'aider il
est invalide guina bien pensée a immigré
en france ou ailleurs pour améliorer son
sort
moi je partirai bien en france mais
regardée j'ai personnes avec qu'il
laissait qui va s'occuper de lui l'égal
guina n'est pas la seule à vouloir
partir kalia vit avec son mari dans
cette baraque 20 euros mensuels dette
sociale pour tous revenus et un désir
profond d'immigrés plus vers l'ouest
vers l'autre europe
moi j'y vais en france même pour mendier
parce qu'ici personne ne fait attention
à nous personne ne nous donne rien ne
serait ce qu'une baguette
florine la vingtaine marié deux enfants
lui avec ses parents ici voilà c'est là
où on dort tous sont à venir
il ne l'imaginent pas en roumanie moi je
pense sérieusement à partir en france à
ramener toute ma famille et si y'a aucun
débouché il n'y a pas de cadeau la
mairie nous dit qu'ils n'ont rien à nous
donner la solution
dina la trouver pour faire vivre ses
frères et soeurs elle est devenue une
habituée des allers retours entre la
région parisienne et la roumanie en
france je bosse dans le recyclage de
métaux la ferraille je fais des
poubelles je gagne 40 à 50 euros par
mois non par jour et nuit sa maison elle
l'a payé grâce à l'aide versée par la
france lors de sa première expulsion
j'ai reçu 300 euros d aide au retour
vous allez retourner en france pour
encore avoir cette aide
non parce qu'on leur donnera plus cette
aide au retour vient peut-être que je
trouverai un français et que je vais me
marier avec lui
un désir d'eldorado pour fuir une
discrimination vécue au quotidien
l'histoire du pont de flou mouche annie
est symbolique et linda et rome ces
enfants utilisaient ce raccourci pour
aller à l'école des roumains l'ont
détruit pour ne plus voir ses gammes à
passer devant leur maison
on les accuse de plusieurs vols les
roumains là où ils ne veulent plus que
nous les roms on passe devant chez eux
et ça c'est depuis qu'on a volé lavage
de monsieur florica on s'en prend
toujours à nous c'est pas vrai vous
savez les roms et les romains on est
tous pareils il ya des bons et des
mauvais comme partout ironie de
l'histoire notre vieille roumaine va
trébucher sur le pont cassé et c'est un
roman qui va l'aider à se relever
merci ça m'a fait plaisir que tu mets et
des des roms qui rêvent d'eldorado qui
se sentent discriminés à la mairie de
funchal ni on ne se sent pas concerné
ce que j'ai observé de plus important
c'est le manque de dialogue entre roms
et roumains depuis longtemps et puis les
roms considère que la mairie peut tout
résoudre
on leur a jamais expliqué que certains
problèmes ne sont pas de notre ressort
d'après jelloud dominé que la question
rom n'est pas prioritaire pour le
gouvernement
son association est de cette population
dans tout le pays est sur le terrain il
constate que les autorités ne font rien
pour retenir ceux qui veulent partir et
pour cause les autorités ont intérêt à
ce qu'il y ait une forte communauté à
l'extérieur du pays
quand on regarde les statistiques tous
les angles les roumains ça inclut les
roms qui sont à l'étranger envoient un
milliard deux cent mille euros c'est une
somme qui représente 1 % du pib saper le
système éducatif
le système de santé en roumanie tous les
salaires sont payés grâce à cet argent
en roumanie il serait plus de deux
millions les roms ils forment le
tiers-monde de l'europe aujourd'hui
légalement ceux qui n'ont pas de contrat
de travail peuvent rester au maximum
trois mois en france voilà pourquoi il
ya encore des expulsions mais en 2014
le cadre légal changera c'est la fin de
la période de transition pour la
roumanie les roms pourront rester aussi
longtemps qu'ils le souhaitent en france
avec la bénédiction des autorités
roumaines un reportage en roumanie signé
ahmed tazir alors nous avons été
rejoints sur ce plateau par cristian
preda bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés
romain vous êtes du groupe ppe ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles
on a vraiment le sentiment qu'en
roumanie à les roumains d'un côté les
hommes de l'autre
est ce que la situation des roms ça fait
l'objet d'un débat national chez vous
oui ça fait débat bien sûr avant que le
débat soit organisé en france et dans
les autres pays membres de l'union
bien sûr ça le débat a pris une
perspectives nouvelles avec le scandale
des expulsions d'il ya deux ans bon
maintenant il faut pas prendre
la roumanie traverse est partout par
cette séparation il ya des communautés
qui sont parfaitement intégrés ou les
roumains les les roms les roumains
d'origine rom vivre ensemble il ya aussi
bien sûr des
et aussi des communautés où cette
séparation existe à cause de la
stigmatisation à cause aussi d'une
d'une culture qui est propre à certains
communauté des roms qui qui ne veulent
pas le contact enfin et qui complique ce
qui complique d'ailleurs de
l'intervention sociale
il a précédé en touche à bhl qui
n'accepte pas des noms roms à
l'intérieur des communautés
alors bien sûr que les médiateurs
sociaux ont du mal à faire le travail
mais c'est pas généraliser il faut pas
comprendre que la roumanie je le répète
est traversé par parcelle de la facture
comme ça non c'est plus compliqué
d'ailleurs ce qui fait que aussi en
europe la situation des roms qui circule
est différente iliad il ya des régions
où ça se passe très bien et chante de
nouveau parfaitement intégrés surtout
quand disons bien sûr du travail et il
ya des situations et sont marginalisés à
la paix dit freddy
et c'est donc ça des produits en quelque
sorte la situation existante aux siens
romaine il n'en pense rien quelques
chopes en quittant la roumanie alors il
ya eu vous le disiez il ya deux ans une
polémique parce que des roms ont été
expulsés de france
c'était lorsque le président nicolas
sarkozy était au pouvoir
cet été de nouveau il ya eu une
polémique alors que maintenant il s'agit
de françois hollande est ce que ça a
changé en tout cas ce que c'est vécu
comme tel
est ce que c'est la même situation
aujourd'hui le paradoxe fait que des
explosions étaient organisés bien avant
que débutent les scandales en 2010 les
chiffres d'ailleurs sont parfaitement
comparable c'est que là la seule
nouveauté il ya deux ans et qu'on a
commencé par des lancers ensuite ce qui
est aussi paradoxal c'est que
la plupart des départs des rentes se
sont faits avant 2007 avoue la lente et
de leurs manies en europe
or ce qui est dit dans le débat public
secret la lenteur de la rumeur de la
roumanie a créé sur les flux c'est pas
vrai parce que la plupart je le répète
de départ c'était bien avant
maintenant bien sûr qu'avec des mesures
qu'ils ont pas toujours bien taillée
j'allais dire l'idée de donner des de
l'argent pour que les
les roms quittent le territoire bon sens
courageux les arrivées parce que les
gens apprennent armani que le
gouvernement français disponible de ne
payer une petite somme bon ils font le
parcours
donc ils font uniquement pour repartir
avec les 3 100 euros bien sûr je dansais
les vraies solutions je crains que
chante à définir au niveau des états
membres en roumanie comme ailleurs où
les roms je trouve maintenant mais aussi
au niveau européen pour chez qui
concerne deux domaines essentiels c'est
à dire l'éducation et la santé
tant que nous n'avons pas un vrai
système de dons très scolaire partout
les roms se trouve maintenant parce
qu'ils ne sont plus en roumanie bulgarie
slovaquie qui sont les trois grands pays
où on retrouve cet énorme minorité
européenne
mais les rampes sont partout alors il
faut s'attendre à voir ces nécessité de
les faire entrer à l'école
ensuite il faut bien sûr voir comment
gérer la question sociale parce qu'il ya
c'est vrai on a en roumanie comme dans
les autres pays où il s'installe un vrai
problème social vue là je veux dire la
fragilité de de l'installation
alors notre reporter en roumanie a
rencontré une étudiante et s'appelle
margareta elle a uni est là une question
à vous poser en écoute
de quoi chiner je vous pose la question
que doivent faire les roms pour être
accepté par les autres européens et que
doivent-ils faire pour ne pas être
expulsé un élément de réponse peut-être
oui un élément c c'est peut-être ce
prénom emmené c'est je crois aussi un
problème de représentation politique
vous voyez dans le scandale qui qui a eu
lieu en france ya deux ans tout le monde
a parlé un les roumains les français les
centres europe 1 mais sauf surprise la
cote chose est sûre les institutions il
ya pas eu beaucoup de voir homme à qui
s'exprime et cela pourquoi parce que à
la différence des autres minorités
nationales qui chante très bien le
présenter en roumanie les roms se sont
pas vraiment bien le présenter il n'y a
pas une vraie mobilisation des
difficultés un roman sur le député
européen mais qui ne vient pas de
remaniement mais de l'envié c'est madame
ya locale qui est membre de notre groupe
et armani aussi pour une population
devant deux millions et avec peut-être
entre 1,5 et 2 millions de roms
on a un seul député aussi qui vient de
cette minorité donc je prends faire
maintenant que la solution ça va être
portée si une vraie mobilisation
politique fait si un nombre important
d'activistes
donc une meilleure voire de réseau sinon
c'est plus important mais en ce sens
sera ma dernière question est ce que
vous pensez que la responsabilité
revient au pays dans lesquels vivent vit
cette minorité aujourd'hui donc entre
autres la roumanie ou est ce que c'est
une responsabilité par exemple de la
france et plus globalement que
l'ensemble de l'europe
non je crois comme comme il s'agit de
citoyens européens de responsabilité
revient à chacun des pays riches où il
choisit de vivre bien sûr il ya encore
des restrictions vous l'avez mentionné
mais il faut s'attendre qu'après 2014
chacun des états membres où ils
choisissent de s'installer fasse quelque
chose pour l'éducation et pour la santé
merci christian preda d'avoir accepté
notre invitation c'est la fin d'europe
hebdo on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine au parlement européen avec
kathia gilder d'ici là bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires